ariane moffatt bonjour je vous fait
vraiment partie de la gamme de
louis-jean cormier pierre lapointe n'a
fait retirer les baux à ce qu'avait dans
l'eau s'était passé à saint lary -
qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient dans la fumée
on est une génération qui s'est
renouvelé un peu comme celle que je
pense qu'on voit en ce moment en
chansons moi je sens un changement de
garde un nouveau son une jeunesse qui
définit pas différemment que nous alors
j'ai l'impression que cette batch là du
début des années 2000 est arrivé à
intégrer des influences ne peut plus
- - font qu'avec des inspirations de la
scène internationale peut-être d'amener
l'électro dans le son de la chanson
populaire
on s'est approprié quelque chose qui
s'est démis ces jeux qui ont qui ont
carmen qui ont été formés aussi on est
allé on étudie en musique que pas
tellement mais ça je pense que c'est un
cap a ramené des outils pour pour une
création parce que je pense à ça parce
que j'étais dans la même cour que louis
gens qui mériteraient on en a grand dam
ici j'apprends que je sais pas belga
chds
peut-être que le fait qu'on se connaisse
concerne concentra et dresse à aider à
nous faire exister comme collectivement
[Musique]
vous êtes vraiment aussi une bête de
studio quel est le moment où vous dites
j'ai le filon il faut faire attention
avec le sakassou ça passe par ce que
j'ai en mémoire
je donne l'exemple la chanson miami de
l'album 22h02 finalement été un des plus
grands succès presque de ma carrière
point de vue radiophonique de la façon
dont les gens m'en parlent
cette chanson là pendant toute la
production de l'album elle a changé de
costume à le changer d'arrangement a
changé de le texte était terminée le
jour où il fallait donner les mixtes
j'enregistrais la voix et tous l'ont
jetée comme votre su faire l'équipe
cette chanson losc et troupes à bonbons
j'avais beaucoup de misère alors j'ai
travaillé et pis j'ai cherché finalement
on a trouvé alors des fois le défaut
signe parce que c'est décourageant une
chanson peut prendre du temps à
retrouver ses beaux habits et il faut
pas lâcher mais sinon moi ça se passe
très très tôt c'est à dire que si
j'écris je suis seul je commence un
processus d'une chanson il y en a
beaucoup que c'est lui qui en a beaucoup
que je sens qu'un non çà çà çà çà va pas
mener loin
y'avait pas de matière qui va perdurer
là-dedans pis je large dit en partant et
une fois qu'ils sont avancés seror que
je les abandonne complètement
[Musique]
le carrefour des grands succès qui nous
colle à la poussée ja rentrer à montréal
et parfois nous fatiguer l'attend pas
alors que goody par évidence quelqu'un
camon b des aînés georges safer fois que
j'en parle que j'en parle au tj mais il
a été hospitalisé dont guina sherbrooke
puis il fallut le transférer à montréal
en ambulance puis mais y aller mieux
type pour ce compte transférer mais je
me répète les inhalothérapeutes et
infirmières ils m'ont dit on ne le
compensent à la chanson je rentre à
montréal on le fait jouer devant du toit
compris que depuis ça le bon petit
crapaud qu'il est dans les clous batteur
ça a pris tout une autre un autre sens à
cette chanson loeb c'est comme si l'aja
ceci juste à ce moment là les mouvements
pour motif mais à ce moment là on a
réussi à trouver quelque chose de
lumineux dans dans ce moment puis ça a
donné comme notre association a la
chance
[Musique]
justement quand vous êtes sur 5 vous
êtes empressé de vieilles chansons à ce
que du sud kivu remonte pas comme ce
soir je vais avoir un invité sur scène
qui est de la nouvelle génération c'est
les louanges qui ouvre puis je l'invité
à chanter avec moi sur un de nos
premiers succès alors là de voir
justement de me revoir à son âge puis de
chanter avec lui qui vient d'arriver
alors que moi j'ai eu plus de quinze ans
de métier ça me ramène c'est sûr pour
moi ça me donne l'impression de une
complétude de quelque chose qui ne sait
pas qui fait un tout que je regarde avec
tendresse je dirais
[Musique]
il ya toute une grande tournée que vous
attend d'ici la fin de l'année il faut
que je pose la question suivante comment
avec trois enfants faites vous pour
jongler avec tout ce monde où j'espère
premièrement parce que je suis pas seul
dans cette aventure leur va conjointe et
est aussi une professionnelle qui a
besoin de travailler mon arrive à
s'arranger pour que les choses se
passent c'est sur mon travail je
travaille le soir j'ai un horaire
atypique mais en même temps j'ai décidé
de ne pas développer la france 2 pas
nécessairement mais d'énergie je pars
jamais très très longtemps j'ai planifié
la tournée avec l'aide de stuc ebooks
les choses de façon à faire une garde
partagée avec cette tournée là c'est à
dire qu'un week-end sur deux je peux ne
pas jouer pour profiter de la campagne
en famille j'équilibre pour faire ça
plus longtemps moins intensément bon à
rien merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]